[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña desde miami el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional y asesor científico
de france 24 en español gracias por
estar con nosotros como siempre doctor y
comienzo a preguntarle dos nuevas
variantes están haciendo presencia en la
región de américa latina una de ellas es
la andina que fue detectada hace unos
tres meses y que ahora en algunos países
es la de mayor circulación qué tan
peligrosa es y por qué lado ms no la ha
categorizado
para que el en este momento está en
evaluación en lado de mdc para ver si se
categoría como se categoriza como una
variante de interés pero este linaje
andino que ha repercutido
importantemente en la región es
responsable de la mitad de los casos en
chile y el crecimiento de los casos en
perú es importante recordar que estos
linajes escapan a una respuesta
inmunológica después de que una
personalidad occovi y puede ser sus
actividad que se infecte con este linaje
de ahí la importancia y la monitoría ya
que se está documentando en otros países
de la región como colombia en
centroamérica y otros países de eso
lamentó entonces qué tipo de prueba
podría determinar esta variante
recordemos que para determinar las
variantes no es con las pruebas de pcr
convencionales sino lo que se llama una
detección genómica una vigilancia que
mónica eso que es es colocar virus que
se han encontrado en cierto tipo de
pacientes y hacer una secuenciación esta
secuenciación se compara con los linajes
en el mundo y se encuentra si son
similares o distintos y esa vigilancia
genómica y la que nos determina que el
imágenes están circulando en los
momentos de la pandemia doctor otra
variante que se conoció esta semana fue
en sao paulo uno de los estados de
brasil más afectados por la pandemia es
la llamada p 4 los investigadores
sospechan que podría derivar de la p 1
que fue la detectada de manaos amazonas
que se sabe de esta variante y podría
ser más peligrosa que el virus común del
joven
siempre vamos a tener inconveniente de
que mientras haya personas que se estén
siendo susceptibles van a aparecer la
imagen esto que nos reportan estado
pablo realmente es preocupante porque
parece un derivado de este p 1
recordemos que era variante pero no es
al menos todos y media veces más
contagiosa que la variante normal que
como sean verídicos y es responsable un
proteína en sao paulo la detección de
esta de estos pacientes pues son un
problema de salud pública porque se
pueden exportar a otros países tener
características diferentes y no se
podrían neutralizar efectivamente con
las vacunas hoy se está evaluando si sí
o no son susceptibles a las vacunas pero
definitivamente es otra también mala
noticia en este desarrollo de la
pandemia
bueno diciendo así como podríamos
identificarla y qué tan grave sería que
atravesará las fronteras
es importante recordar que en los
linajes independientemente lo que son
las mismas medidas de protección son
efectivas distanciamientos el uso de
mascarillas de higiene de manos y la
ventilación está en este momento
hablando ser 2 kos si en estos linajes
son más virulentos es decir enferman más
y si las vacunas que estamos aplicando
en la región son susceptibles y al
parecer en la mayoría de variantes las
vacunas y siguen esperemos que en estas
también pero en un par de meses vamos a
poder verificar esta información y ya
apareciera un cambio de tono y una nueva
noticia sobre la vacuna de moderna y su
efectividad en adolescentes que se
conoce al respecto
es una muy buena noticia porque cerca
del 100 por ciento de las personas
adolescentes de los cables sean de entre
12 y 17 años que con la plataforma de
rené a de la oratoria moderna mostraron
su estudio en 3.500 voluntarios
efectividad eso abre una muy buena
noticia a que nuestros adolescentes y
muy en un futuro inmediato los niños
hagan parte del esquema de vacunación y
así logramos la inmunidad del año que
necesitamos tanto en nuestras regiones
genéticas
y para el cierre muy rápidamente doctor
el llamado a vacunarnos
es muy importante recordar que las
vacunas son seguras efectivas y que la
forma para evitar la pandemia si nos
vacunamos evitamos los linajes si nos
vacunamos no nos enfermamos entonces un
llamado a ponernos y la buena noticia de
que los adolescentes pronto entre dando
cosas que no de vacunación en la región
y mientras nos llega a seguir usando
tapabocas ya lavar las manos gracias
doctor ya nuestros televidentes
continúen con nosotros en france24 buen
día
[Música]